whereas to prove that if a line is
parallel to one side of a triangle then
it divides the other two sides
proportionately so pause this video and
see if you can do that and you might
want to leverage this diagram all right
so let's work through this together so
we can start with this diagram and what
we know is that segment edie is parallel
to segment CB so we can write that down
segment e d is parallel to segment C B
and so segment D is what they're talking
about that is a line or a line segment
that is parallel to one side of the
triangle so really given what we know
and what's already been written over
here on this triangle we need to prove
another way of writing it another way of
saying it divides the other two sides
proportionately is that the ratio
between the part of the original
triangle side that is on one side of the
dividing line to the length on the other
side is going to be the same on both
sides that it is intersecting so another
way to say that it divides the other two
sides proportionately if we look at this
triangle over here it would mean that
the length of segment AE over the length
of segment EC is going to be equal to
the length of segment ad over the length
of segment D B this statement right over
here and what I underlined up here are
equivalent given this triangle so the
way that we can try to do it is to
establish similarity between triangle
AED and triangle a C B so how do we do
that well because these two lines are
parallel we can view segment AC as a
transversal intersecting two parallel
lines so that tells us that these two
corresponding angles are going to be
congruent so we could say that angle one
is congruent to angle three and the
reason why is because they are
corresponding corresponding angles
I'm just trying to write a little bit of
shorthand this is short for
corresponding angles that's the
rationale and we also know that angle 2
is congruent to angle 4 for the same
reason so angle 2 is congruent to angle
4 once again because they are
corresponding angles this time we have a
different transversal corresponding
angles where a transversal intersects
two parallel lines and so now if you
look at triangle AED and triangle ACB
you see that they have two sets of
corresponding angles that aren't
congruent and if you have two sets of
corresponding angles that means that all
of the angles are congruent you actually
see that over here if you care about it
but two is enough but you actually have
a third because angle I could call it
BAC is common to both triangles and so
we can say that triangle a II D is
similar to triangle ACB a CB by
angle-angle similarity similarity and
then given that these two are similar
then we can set up a proportion that
tells us that the ratio of the length of
segment AE to this entire side to AC a/c
is equal to the ratio of ad the length
of that segment to the length of the
entire thing to a B now this implies
that I'm just going to start writing it
to the right here to save space this is
the same thing as the ratio of a e over
AC is AE plus EC's length so AE s length
plus e sees length and then this is
going to be equal to the length of
segment ad over segment a-b it's length
is the length of segment ad a
plus segment DB plus DB now really what
I need to do is figure out how do I
algebraically manipulate it so I get
what I have up here let me scroll down a
little bit so one way I could try to
simplify this is to essentially cross
multiply that's equivalent to
multiplying both sides by both of these
denominators and we've covered that in
other videos and so this is going to be
equal to the length of segment AE times
a D plus DB those segment lengths that's
got to be equal to length of ad times a
plus the length of segment EC and I can
distribute this over here I have length
of segment AE times length of segment ad
plus length of segment AE times length
of segment DB is equal to length of
segment ad times length of segment AE
plus length of segment ad times length
of segment e C and let's see is there
anything that I can simplify here well I
have it AE times ad on both sides so let
me just subtract AE times ad from both
sides and so then I'm just left with
that this is equal to that so scroll
down a little bit more and let me
actually just rewrite this cleanly so I
have a e times d b is equal to a d times
e see these are all the segment lengths
right over here now if you divide both
sides by EC you're going to get an EC
down here and then this would cancel out
and then if you divide both sides by DB
this will cancel out and you'll get a DB
right over here
so if you just algebraically manipulate
what we just had over there you get that
the length of segment AE over the length
of segment EC length of segment AE over
the length of segment EC is equal to the
length of segment a d ay
d over the length of segment DB which is
exactly what we wanted to prove that
this line right over here that is
parallel to this side over here divides
the other two sides proportionately